(Upbeat music)
♪ You, you ♪
♪ I don't need a tree full of gifts, ♪
♪ I didn't even make a list. ♪
- About yours in an hour?
I'm picking up chips.
What's your dip pairing?
- It's movie marathon day so,
- (together) Queso deluxe.
- I'm a get my face in that cheese.
- I'm a eat so much cheese I'm going
to give myself a heart condition.
(laughter)
- Oh my god we must stop.
All right, okay bye K-star,
dollar sign, pot money crunch.
- Bye I hate you.
Woof man, my balls just
retracted into my body.
- What?
Tell her that you like her.
- That's you know I'm going to.
Today.
(electric razor)
- Ah.
- Hey what's up?
- I'm up thanks, I'm good.
Yeah I'm up good.
- Okay see you downstairs
when you've found a bra.
So do you remember JP Lapierre?
- JP Lapierre?
Soccer captain from the grade above us?
- Yeah anyway he's home and he invited us
to his college friends' party today.
- Us?
- Well I mean he invited
me, but would you wanna go?
- With you and JP Lapierre?
- I don't know I think it could be fun.
But like I, if you're
down, if you're not don't,
if you don't want to go that's fine, but,
- No no no no I mean,
if you want to go then.
- Really appreciate a buddy.
- Totally, I am that.
- Seriously I am getting
a band aid for your boob.
So is Carla okay to drive us?
- Oh she's talked about nothing else.
- Did she get a lot of work done?
- On the deal, she got new brake pads,
her hood ornaments been straightened,
her side panels buffed.
- Tastefully done, you can hardly tell.
Very festive.
♪ could not get her face out of my mind ♪
♪ on the haunted heart
of a hopeless romantic ♪
♪ I swore I would not
miss what I left behind. ♪
- Angie you made it.
- Hey, this is my friend Tobin.
- I know Tobin.
- You do?
- Course man you sat behind me in physics.
- Yeah I knew that, I just
didn't think you knew that.
- Come on man bring it in.
Oh yeah.
So you guys played broom ball?
- Love broom ball.
- All right sweet you're
on my team, come on man.
- You love broom ball?
I've never heard you
once mention broom ball.
- Because I don't like
talking about broom ball
I love playing broom ball.
I'm nice on the ice.
Which is a phrase other people
have used to describe me,
at how good I am at broom ball.
- Okay because you usually
never like to pay sport.
- Broom ball is not a sport,
it's a leisurely holiday pastime.
Besides who are we playing,
the broom ball Olympians?
- Yo JP!
- Holy shit.
- We came to play.
You guys ready or what?
- The Restin brothers?
This is their party?
I thought they went to jail?
- No I think the witness
had a change of heart.
- Hey man saw you roll
up in your pussy wagon.
(laughter)
- That's clever.
♪ Christmas time, ♪
- JP!
♪ the world so fine, ♪
- I'm open.
(exhales)
(crash)
- Homeboy's gonna feel it.
- You all right?
- Yeah I'm all good.
- Gotta try and stay vertical my man.
Ooh get you back out there all right.
Come on.
♪ you've got to do your thing. ♪
- Back up back up, you've got this T,
you've got this T.
Come on step up, step up.
(crash)
(cheer)
- Hey man I just want
to apologize for them,
that wasn't cool
- No that's cool, that's cool.
- No no no no you can be
reasonable and calm about it,
but I'm not.
It's not okay what they did to you.
- So what do you say
we get out of here huh?
- Uh yeah I'm down.
- Same.
- And were taking their keg.
(funky music)
(crash)
- Let's go
- Come on buddy.
- That's our keg, that's
our keg. Get in the car man.
- Hit it, hit it
- Go go go go go.
(engine revs)
(cheer)
- Keep going.
- I'm trying
- Why are we slowing down?
- No no no no.
- Wait.
- Oh god.
- Okay.
Oh god.
- Incoming
- Come on Carla, like
don't be a little bitch.
- Yeah Carla work that
ass like I know you can.
- I know it's a car, but
I'm also a feminist, so
(crash)
(shout)
- Come on man
- Okay come on, come on, lets go.
- Yeah come on let's go.
- There we go, there we go.
- Come on they're right
behind us bud, come on.
- Come on come on come on.
- Turn right, turn right.
(wheel spin)
(screams)
- Yeah woo.
- Way to go man.
- Yes Carla.
- That was insane
- Seriously T-Rex, you're a hero man,
some action hero shit the way
we were sliding and drifting,
(tire pops)
- Guys, guys, what's
happening, press the brake.
- I'm trying
- Whoa.
- I am pressing the brake,
I am pressing the break.
- No no no no
(crash)
- We're in a ditch.
- Can't believe I'm
hiding out in a church .
- Wow, look at this thing
Oh my god Tobin play something.
- No way man, you play?
- Yeah he's so good.
(organ chime)
- Tob play whole of the moon.
(organ music)
♪ I pictured a rainbow you
held it in your hand, ♪
♪ I had flashes but you saw the plan. ♪
♪ I wondered out in the world for years ♪
♪ though you just stayed in your room. ♪
♪ I saw the crescent you
saw the whole of the moon. ♪
♪ the whole of the moon. ♪
♪ You were there in the turnstiles, ♪
♪ with the wind at your heels. ♪
♪ You stretched for the stars
and you know how it feels ♪
♪ to reach too high, too far, too soon. ♪
♪ You saw the whole of the moon. ♪
♪ I spoke about wings. ♪
♪ You just flew, I wondered
I guessed and I tried. ♪
♪ You just knew I sighed. ♪
♪ But you swooned I saw the crescent ♪
♪ you saw the whole of the moon. ♪
♪ The whole of the moon. ♪
♪ Unicorns and cannonballs,
palaces and piers ♪
♪ Trumpets, towers and tenements
wide oceans full of tears ♪
♪ Flags, rags ferryboats ♪
♪ Scimitars and scarves ♪
♪ Every precious dream and vision ♪
♪ Underneath the stars, yes,
you climbed on the ladder ♪
♪ With the wind in your sails ♪
♪ You came like a comet ♪
♪ Blazing your trail, ♪
- Tobin shall we play sound of vision.
- No I'm all good.
- What?
- Come on man one more
- No I think I'm going to check on Cara,
the guys are probably gone no by now so,
- no wait, we can all go.
- I'm going to go alone.
- Can I talk to you for a minute, hey
- what
- What do you mean what?
You're being weird, leaving suddenly
how is that being weird?
- Tobin
- Angie.
- Why are you calling me Angie?
- Isn't that what you liked to be called?
- God since when did you get so sensitive?
- Okay are you mad about JP?
- Why would I be mad about JP?
- Are you jealous?
- Yeah Angie I'm jealous of JP.
- I'm jealous of the enlightened,
broom ball playing,
meditating college boy.
- Fine be that way.
(sad music)
(guitar)
♪ it's okay to have scars,
they'll make you who you are. ♪
♪ It's okay to have fear as
long as you're not scared of, ♪
(knocking)
- Hey, so I'm gonna go to this thing.
This party, JP's friends party.
- Cool cool.
I'm just waiting for the tow truck,
then I should probably deliver this keg.
- Have a great fun, have a great time,
have a great, have a great time is what,
I wanted to say have fun
and have a great time at the same time.
- No I got it.
- Hey
- Angie I'm in love with you,
and it's not like in a
traditional sense or anything,
it's more like I think of
you every moment of the day,
I just want you to think
I'm cool all the time.
You know when something funny happens,
you're the only person I want to tell.
When something sad happens,
just want to know if you think it's sad.
And when I saw you with
JP, I wanted to kill him.
I actually wanted to murder him.
I want to be with you for
the rest of my life Angie.
- Wow.
That was actually all pretty traditional.
- Yeah it was.
It was pretty traditional.
As soon as I said it I, yeah.
- Now I want to tell you something.
I freaked out about it being you for me.
But it is you, it's always been you.
(upbeat music)
♪ I pictured a rainbow, ♪
♪ you held it in your hands, ♪
- Can I ask you a question?
Can we still hang out
with JP, I like that guy.
- Yeah.
Can I ask you a question.
- What the hell are you wearing?
- I'm a wise man
♪ I saw the crescent ♪
♪ You saw the whole of the moon ♪